you talked yesterday about his taxes and
some people saw some irony here because
Harry Reid and others speculated about
your taxes before you put them out and
what might be in there do you know
something about what might be in his
taxes I do have some informed guests or
are you doing what one of your older
grandkids might call trolling actually I
indicated why I said what I did and why
I believe there's a bombshell in his
taxes and that is because every time
someone has raised the question of his
taxes he evades and you don't do that if
you are planning on releasing them he
began by saying they're beautiful
they're bold they're beautiful and he
was gonna release them and then as time
has gone on he keeps coming up with new
excuses why he won't release them most
recent of course was old they're being
audited he said four or five years are
being audited well then he said no it's
two or three years so the response is
well okay give us the taxes that aren't
being audited and somehow he won't do
that either so I think everyone has the
same evidence I do which is he does not
want to release his tax returns under
any circumstances I don't believe he
ever will
because there's something in there that
he's afraid that if the people saw it
they wouldn't vote for him for the
nominee would it be enough for him to
release his income his effects of tax
rate and his charitable contribution oh
no I what is it what weld bead what
would be the right level it's for
candidates for office have traditionally
given their text returns and whether
it's one year or five years or two years
you know I provided my tax returns in
the year that I had them completed in
January of 2012 we're now in March of
this election year it's late to be
releasing returns he ought to be doing
it